He is recognized as the greatest athletes
of modern times in the boxing ring,
that he was nothing short of superb
punishing his opponent so well and it was
outside of the ring that he would have
his greatest battles and show the world
what it really meant to be a man.
And this episode of Biographics,
we discovered what it was that made
a Mohammad Ali the absolute greatest.
It's just a job.
Grass grows,
birds fly waves pounding the sand.
I'd beat people up.
Cassius Marcellus clay was born on
January the 17th of 1942 in Louisville,
Kentucky.
His father,
Cassius Sr was it east sign paints out
while his mother Adesa worked as a maid
for a wealthy White Family in Louisville
are precocious but polite child.
Young Cassius was raised as a god
fearing baptist along with his younger
brother,
Rudy and his younger years.
He gave no indication
to his athletic future.
He steered clear of sports,
preferring to play marbles with Rudy Ball,
read comic books on his bed in
1954 when he was 12 years old,
Casios and a friend rode their
bicycles to the Columbia Auditorium,
which was hosting the
Louisville home show.
They spent the afternoon checking out
the wares of various African American
merchants and gorging themselves on the
Free Popcorn and candy that was on offer
when they emerge from the exhibition.
The boys were dismayed to discover the
Cassius as brands new red and white.
A Schwinn bike was missing the why.
Well,
it had been stolen.
Cassius was absolutely livid
with rage drawing an upset.
He began asking people if
they'd seen who took his bike.
A woman suggested that he reported the
theft to officer Joe Martin who operated
a boxing gym in a nearby basement finding.
Martin Cassius explained
to what has happened.
I think that he was going to
wobble whoever had taken his bike,
Marta,
and it had been teaching
boxing for decades,
asked if the boy knew how to fight.
When Cassius admitted this,
he didn't.
The officers suggested
that maybe he has a learn.
Well this,
this was the beginning of a long
friendship and to Glorious Korea,
Huh?
Cassius.
He threw himself into boxing training
with a passion and commitment that
impressed Martin.
Although we had it very
little natural skill,
he had more heart than
anyone else in the gym.
It raced to the gym as soon as school let
out and would train even on Saturdays.
Martin had simply never seen a kid
work quite so hot outside of the gym.
Cassius stayed away from anything that
would interfere with his training.
He was displaying the
kind of determination and
discipline that was lacking in
many of the older boxes
that Martin coached Martin.
He introduced Cassius to at local boxing
trainer named Fred stoner who helped
teach him the fundamentals of the sport
under the guidance of these two men,
young play began winning one man.
What about after another
month after month,
year after year,
a handful of amateur winds
built up a formidable records.
By the age of 18 he had won 108 bouts,
six Kentucky Golden Glove Championships
and two national Aau titles in the ring.
Cassius absolutely fearless.
He carried a self confidence and a belief
in his ability that put his opponents
off guard before the first
ground bell met even sounds it,
but this was in great contrast to his
personal life because there he really
struggles.
It was a poor student with teachers
unable to understand why he couldn't
transfer the dedication you put
into his sport into his studies.
No one realized at the time that has
struggles in school they would do to the
reading disability dyslexia in
February of 1957 professional boxer,
but Willie Per Strano visited
Louisville with his trainer,
Angelo Dundee Cassius found out where
he was staying and phoned for Strano his
hotel room.
If I was picked up by done deep,
Cassius blurted out that he was going to
be the world's greatest boxer and that
he wanted to meet for Strano
with nothing on their schedule.
That afternoon done the infrastructure
actually invited Cassius.
Do you have a hotel room
for the next several hours?
Cassius peppered Australia with questions
only pausing long enough to predict
his own future.
Greatness of amused Angelo.
Dundee was impressed with the boy ends.
Kept in touch with him.
He's sometimes since Cassius and his
family free tickets when one of his boxes
had a fight in lines up in Louisville.
In March,
1959 Cassius was training
in a gym in Chicago,
Illinois prior to an Aau talks bout,
yeah,
the hood.
Some other boxes talking about a group
called the nation of Islam who were re
spousing black pride back.
I'm in Louisville.
He decided to learn more about the
group by doing a school assignment about
them.
However,
his teacher shut the idea down,
telling him that the group was dangerous
and that they preached hatred against
all white people.
Play,
however,
was still intrigued by
the nation of Islam.
He got ahold of a copy of a newspaper
that they put out and started reading as
much as he could about them.
At the same time,
he was wrestling with the weighty
decision about what direction to take his
boxing future.
People that have been talking him up as
a hot prospect for the 1960 Olympics in
Rome,
but at that time only amateurs are
able to compete in the Olympics,
so he had to decide if he was going to
town professional or compete in Rome as
part of the United States is boxing team.
It was at this point 30 turned to
his friend Angelo Dundee for advice,
don't told Cassius that he could earn
more money as a pro if he was an Olympic
champion.
First.
As a result,
he decided to stay in his amateur
career runs compete in the Olympics.
Well,
at the time the American Olympic
team was set to depart for Italy.
Playing was in peak physical condition
and mentally primed for victory,
but there was one slight problem.
He was absolutely terrified at
the prospect of flying on a plane.
In fact,
he was so terrified that he always passed
up the opportunity to represent his
country.
He,
he finally relented when it's old
mentor Joe Martin convinced him to fly.
We think parachute on his back.
Fortunately it Cassius,
it didn't need to operate
as parachutes in the plane.
Touched down in room
without any incidents.
He started as an employee campaign with
a quick two rounds when over Belgium's
Yvonne,
because that wind was followed by another
win over the Soviet Union's getting
reduced shat cough.
He was the previous gold medal
winner at the 1956 Olympics.
Cassius then triumphed in the semifinals,
defeating Australia's Antony Madigan.
The only person standing between play
and Olympic glory was Poland's is a big
new patters as Koski in
the contrast of Cassius,
who would only been boxing for six years.
This man was a three time
European champion and even
at one bronze in the 1956
Olympics.
However,
it was clay who played
the more aggressive game,
throwing an avalanche of punches to take
the first round lead the Polish champ.
Well,
he was simply unable to recover
and at the ends of three rounds,
Cassius claimed the Olympic,
a light heavyweight gold metal gaseous.
He returns to Louisville eight local
hero with even the mayor turning out to
receive him.
He was so proud of his victory that
he wore his gold medal everywhere.
About a week after his return,
he had a friend's doctor into our
restaurant to get out of the rain.
That's when they tried to order a
couple of cheeseburgers and milkshakes.
They were told that the restaurants did
not serve black people and they were
thrown out.
Cassius clay was an Olympic champion.
Yes,
it was still a second class citizen
in his hometown standing on the second
street bridge.
He grabbed his gold medal,
ripped it from his neck and
threw it into the Ohio river.
Despite his frustration
with the social climates,
Cassius was facing a bright boxing
future turning professional.
He was sponsored by a group of local
white businessmen who agreed to sponsor
him.
They offered to pay him at $10,000 up
front and to cover all of his training
expenses.
In return,
they would take half his
earnings for the next six years.
Despite these impressive
victories in Rome,
boxing pundits didn't expect
a great career for clay.
The consensus was that
he had quick footwork,
but not much else.
He spent too much energy.
They said dancing around the ring man's.
When he lands back to protect his face,
he would leave his body exposed.
However,
Cassius relied on his long reach to strike
his opponents from a distance gaseous
well.
He wanted to train under Angelo Dundee,
but as sponsors sent him to California
to work with a trainer by the name of
Archie Moore.
He made his pro debut in front of his
home crowd on October the 29th of 1960 his
opponent was Tonya,
hadn't sacco clay one the fights
with a unanimous six round decision.
It was a great start to his pro career,
but to clay.
Wasn't happy with Archie Moore,
his training style,
and he headed to Miami and doest Angelo
Dundee to take over as his trainer dumb.
He agrees,
but it meant the Cassius had to live
in a very rough neighborhood that was
filled with gangs and
drugs and prostitution.
Still,
he took immediately to his new training
environments flourishing under the
tutelage of date.
By now,
it became evident that Cassius was an
absolutely masterful self promoter.
In fact,
his mouth,
it worked faster than his fists.
He never tired of announcing
that he was the greatest,
the prettiest,
and the fastest athlete
to ever step into a ring.
But he was soon encouraged
to talk himself up even more.
In June of 1961 clay travel to
Las Vegas for a boxing match.
While in Vegas,
you went to see a wrestler by the name
of Gorgeous George Cassius watched as
George acted outrageously.
He was trash talking his opponent for
an upcoming match he talked to endlessly
before band,
even during the match,
the whole crowd,
well that made them
read for the other guy.
But after the match,
Cassius met George backstage.
The rest of their explained that is self
promotion was designed to get as many
people as possible to pay to come
and see someone shut his mouth.
He advised clay to keep sassing his
opponents and to always be outrageous.
He also told him to find himself a
gimmick that would set himself apart.
Well,
clay,
he soon found his gimmick.
He would predict the round
that he would win the match him
well.
November the 15th 1962 Cassius
met his former trainer,
Archie Moore in the ring,
but bold claims that
he had developed a lip,
a button,
a punch,
do finally silence the Louisville lip
as Cassius had come to be known in
response play,
predicted a fourth round knock outs,
bands.
That is precisely how the fight went down.
Cassius,
he was now a 16 when zero loss pro,
he felt he had an under shot at the
heavyweight world champion Sonny Liston.
He engaged upon a campaign of taunting
list and into taking the challenge.
They began referring to the champ as a
big ugly bear once even travel to his
home town of Springfield,
Colorado and banged on his door at three
in the morning to call out the champ
clay.
He made absolutely sure the TV cameras
were recording every second of this
charade.
Finally listed,
well,
he had had enough and he
agreed to take on the upstart.
The heavyweight champ made a prediction
of his own and that would be pain.
There was no idle threats.
Listing was a mountain of a
man who had a killer punch.
He was considered by many
boxing experts to be unbeatable.
Cassius,
he trained hard for this,
the biggest fight of his life,
but he didn't give it his absolute focus.
Both Cassius and his brother,
Rudy,
they were becoming increasingly
interested in the nation of Islam.
They started attending meetings and
Cassius became enamored with the leader
Elijah Muhammad.
He also took a great liking
to the group spokesman,
knock Max.
As the brothers started spending
more time at the mosque in Miami,
Malcolm told Cassius to where his nation
of Islam membership proudly when the
title find sponsors learned that the
challenger was associating with the nation
of Islam.
They threatened to cancel the event
unless he disavowed the grip it's played.
He would not abandon his newfound faith.
He was prepared to walk away from
boxing to stay true to himself.
Well,
the sponsors,
they ultimately backed
down and the fight he did.
Go ahead.
Now listen.
He was used to knocking out opponents,
the early rounds,
but clay,
he was too fast.
It's quick feet,
danced around the ring.
Anz Liston was simply unable to touch
him after a grueling six rounds.
Liston,
he refused to come out for the seventh
the 22 year old Cassius clay was now the
youngest heavyweight champ in
history as razor sharp canon is.
When was it was superseded the very next
day when he officially announced that
he was a member of the nation of Islam
and that he was changing his name to
Cassius x.
A week later,
that evolved into Muhammad Ali,
the nation of Islam.
They were very unpopular
with most of America.
It was predicted this,
if he fought list,
and again,
there wouldn't be anyone rooting for him.
Well,
the two they did meet again on May the
25th 1965 many in the anxious crowds.
They expect it to see Liston win back the
title that he had lost Ali and instead
they were stunned to see the former champ
again knocked out in the first rounds.
On November the 22nd 1965 Ali successfully
defended his title against former
champ,
Floyd Patterson.
Patterson had spoken out against the
nation of Islam and refuse to call alley
buying his Muslim name,
Ali.
They didn't pay for this slight
mercilessly pounding him while yelling.
Watched my na in 1966 alley defended his
title five times four of those defenses
being held outside of the United States.
On February the sixth 1967
he fought it Ernie to realm.
Then Houston,
Texas to rail was enraged dally buying
just like Floyd Patterson before him
refusing the call only by his name.
The result was what many believe to be
the worst beating ever dished out in a
professional boxing match.
The champion tortured DRL
it for the full 15 rounds,
bringing him up just short of a knockout
and then backing off only to wallop
them again with the combinations.
Ali won a unanimous points decision.
Yeah,
Holly's next bottle.
Would it pit him against the might
of the United States governments?
On April the 28th 1967 he turns up at
the Houston Induction Center for the US
armed forces.
When the time came for him to step forward
to signify signifying his induction,
Allie didn't move.
He explains that his religious beliefs
prevented him from joining the army and
killing people with
whom he had no quarrel.
He further stated that he could not in
good conscious give support to a war that
he felt was morally wrong.
Within 24 hours,
Sally had been stripped of his heavyweight
title as well as his license to box
in every state in the
country in an instant.
That title he had worked so
hard for was simply gone.
When the u s government
took away his passport,
couldn't even box oversees
the governments well.
They had effectively
taken away his livelihood.
However,
the champ was never going to lie down.
He became an unlikely hero to the millions
of young anti war activists around
the nation.
He spoke at the most
prestigious universities where
he was introduced as the
first national figure with the courage
to stand up against the war in Vietnam.
Still,
the late 1960s were lean years fanny.
On August 17th,
1967 he married Belinda Boyd,
but next year they had a child,
Merriam but Ali's name.
It brought him opportunities and
he managed to make ends meet.
He did everything from
opening a restaurant,
calls Champ Burgers to starring
in a musical big time buck white.
As the years passed,
Mohammad continued training and the
hope that one day I would get the
opportunity to reclaim his title.
Finally,
towards the end of the 1970s
some promoters in Georgia,
which didn't have the boxing commission
organized about against Jerry Quarry,
though slower than he had been Helene,
one in a convincing fashion is now.
Well other states they considered
to let him fight again.
If he could get another
win under his belt,
he might even get a shot at a
reigning champion of Joe Fraser.
Does it get up?
Fraser?
I'm Molly has a Festa feet.
Oscar Bonavena the fight
almost when the full 15 rounds,
we've Bonavena taking a
great deal of punishments,
but he also dish down to a level of
abuse that Mohammed had never had to
withstands before.
Sill Molly one in the last round.
Tko the fight of the century,
the first ever between two undefeated
heavyweight champs took place on March the
eighth 1971 phrasing Angelina.
It traded blow after blow five years
before that he would have easily dodged.
Some are phrases,
punches person.
Now he could only take the hits and
fight through the pain and the abuse,
the fight,
they went the distance.
It could have gone either way,
but in the end it was a
unanimous decision to Fraser,
Muhammad Ali.
He had suffered his first
professional loss still.
He was determined to get back on top.
He followed up is lost by
winning 10 fights in a row,
but it is 11th he was stopped
by the formidable can.
Norton who broke his jaw,
but Ali,
he came back in a rematch knocking out
Norton in the six rounds and ends up
after this.
Well that came the rematch that he was
really after he fought Joe Frazier who
had lost his title to George Foreman
for the second time on January the 28th
1974 winning in a 12
rounds unanimous decision.
But Ali,
well,
he still did not have his
title back to claim it.
He would have to defeat to the new champ.
This was the 24 year old foreman who would
so far at one 40 fights and just lost
eight hadn't gone past the
second rounds on paper.
It looked like the 32 year old
elite did not have a chance.
The fighter took place in consortia Zaia
on October the 30th 1974 over the early
rounds.
It appeared as if Ali was out of his depth
with form and apparently pounding him
at will.
What are the was actually doing was
allowing foreman to punch himself to
exhaustion and the
eight rounds at Mommy's,
it came to life and delivered
a devastating series of blows.
The put foreman on the canvas the champion
had reclaimed is heavyweight title.
A year later,
he faced drew Fraser for the third
time and he believed that this was the
hardest fought heavyweights clash
of all time rounds after rounds.
The stunned crowd watched in horror as
the battered boxes somehow fought beyond
exhaustion and the ends ballet was
declared the winner in the 14th rounds.
He was so exhausted that he
couldn't even stand up to celebrate.
Yeah,
an aging all the defendant,
his title seven more times before squaring
up to an unknown challenger by the
name of Leon Spinks on February the
15th 1978 I'll leave underestimated the
challenger training lightly and it's
not taking the fight seriously enough.
That night he lost his title to a man
who didn't deserve to be in the ring with
him at his prime.
Eight months later to smoke obvious
signs of developing Parkinson's disease,
he avenged the loss to claim an
unprecedented third world heavyweight
championship.
Nine months later,
he retired from the ring,
but is time out of the ring
would last for less than a year.
On October the 18th 1980 he suffered
a crushing defeat at the hands of his
former sparring partner.
30 homes.
A year later,
he was dispatched by a far less
impressive Trevor Burdick time.
Well,
it had finally caught up with
Mohammed Ali over the next decade,
has Parkinson's disease
steadily got worse?
The body that had served him so
well was giving up on him still,
he wasn't done yet.
In the late 1980s Mohammed Ali embarked
on a new career as a humanitarian
statesmen and its promotion
of Tolerance and peace weld,
right?
But at the time he left us on June the
third 2016 he was recognized as one of
the great men and certainly the
greatest athlete of the 20th century.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do give it a thumbs up below
and do not forget to subscribe if you
haven't already for brand new videos
just like this every Monday and every
Thursday.
Also check out some of our other videos
from the past over there on the right.
You'll probably enjoy
these if you enjoy those.
They're all biographies.
They're all of notable
people like Muhammad Ali.
We've got loads of others.
Check those ones out on the
rice and maybe what some others,
if you've got some time,
and as always,
thank you for watching.
Okay.